what would happen if you gave up bread
for 14 days
let's talk about that what's in bread
well you have gluten
you have refined grains sugar
starch you have sometimes even
flavorings
you have conditioners for the texture of
the bread
mold inhibitors phytates which actually
will block your zinc your calcium and
your iron
and glyphosate which is an herbicide
so number one you would feel less
bloating
why because so many people either have
an allergy to gluten
or they have gluten intolerance so
they're gonna have a lot of inflammation
in their gut and that's gonna lead to
bloating not to mention the refined
carbohydrates in general
are going to create bloating so you'll
have less bloating number two
you'll have more zinc calcium and iron
okay three your head's gonna feel a lot
better less
brain fog more mental clarity less
headaches
better memory more attention
less adhd that's cool
number four a better mood less irritable
because your blood sugars are going to
be better less anxiety
less depression there's a connection
between what's happening in your gut
or what you just ate and what's going on
up here so you're just going to feel
overall much better with your mood
number five
less pain and inflammation not only
does the gluten cause inflammation but
the refined carbs and the sugar
will increase your inflammation so if
you have arthritis
fibromyalgia all that's going to be much
better
anything itis is going to be better
number six
more weight loss less belly fat because
you're going to have less insulin
number seven more energy okay number
eight less
diabetic symptoms and lower a1c well
actually i like you might not have a
lower a1c because that usually takes
like three months
and if you just check it after 14 days
you might not see a change
but you should see better blood sugar
levels
number nine decrease ldl
and less oxidation in your arteries
that's cool and 10 you're gonna have
more vitamin e in your body and
you're gonna have more b vitamins why
because refined
grains refined carbohydrates deplete you
of vitamin e and the vitamins what's
that going to do it's going to help you
breathe better
it's going to give you more endurance
with your heart you're going to have
less angina attacks your heart's just
going to work a lot better
and you also have less oxidation in the
arteries which is going to decrease the
risk of getting a clot
or a clogged artery because vitamin e is
the major antioxidants to protect you
but other than these 10 things you know
i can't think of any other
good things that can happen so i don't
know try it out
give up bread for 14 days and let me
know what happens
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from
any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story please
share it
in the link down below